you
[Music]
this morning on the dish scene McHugh of
the restaurant cured the San Antonio
eatery is specializing in chicanery it's
part of a next next wave of diversifying
cuisines in the Texas city but the name
of the restaurant signifies a whole lot
more to me more than me McHugh as you're
about to find out inside Chef Steve
McHugh San Antonio restaurant
diners are greeted by a massive
humidity-controlled meat locker known as
the shark tank
the Turku nuri inside serves as an
accused signature dish and a philosophy
for honoring the farmers whose livestock
it depends on we made a commitment early
on that we were gonna purchase entire
animals and then from there figure out
what the heck we were gonna do with this
does that really sell oh yeah
for probably about 95% of people
sometimes people walk in ago I didn't
need to see that but we weren't going to
hide it in the back we really wanted to
just say this is what you get this is
what it is that's the tank is filled
with various meats and salami Zin
different stages of curing or salting so
that's an inside round in Italian they
call it brizola okay and it's it's dried
beef the length of the curing process is
determined by size
McHugh says one ham can take about two
years and the aroma just kind of comes
out at ya it's like walking into a
little ham shop in Italy we're
definitely not trying to weird people
out we're not trying to freak them out
this is stuff people been doing for
centuries it's come in have a good time
enjoy some cured meats and be a little
adventurous exactly yeah this is a
typical charcuterie platter we have
about 22 to 25 different items they can
choose from and it just depends on what
they want to try
there's probably our top seller right
here it's our duck ham we have a chicken
sausage here so it's not just oh it's
not just pork I got to try that the
platter comes with local cheeses house
pickled veggies and mustards should I
have some of it yeah
even the garnishes are beautifully
delicious but when I'm pretty little
flowers on there
if McHugh seems comfortable with a
farm-to-table approach it's because he
grew up that way his parents both
working professionals raised their seven
boys on a dairy farm in Wisconsin I
really in a lot of ways think they
bought it to keep us out of trouble but
at the same time it was a way for them
to provide food to said family McHugh
worked as a short-order cook in high
school but went to college on a
scholarship to study the saxophone I
wasn't the best student in high school
and so then I was a not the best student
in college sitting in a lecture hall all
day learning about music theory and you
know just yeah I didn't want to do it so
I ended up going to culinary school and
I think it was the first time in my life
that I was like top of my class in
anything it was the first time that I
felt really good and it was like making
music but with food or on a play after
graduating from the Culinary Institute
of America McHugh improvised his way to
New Orleans New Orleans was amazing
because it was like going to another
country in the mid 90s and that's what
it felt like it felt like I'd left the
United States and was in a totally
different place he spent 14 years
working for some of the biggest
restaurant tours in the Big Easy then he
was asked to help open a restaurant in
San Antonio when did you decide I'm
gonna strike out on my own well a lot of
things happen but the biggest thing that
happened was when I got sick in 2009
McHugh didn't know he was living with
non-hodgkins lymphoma I was you know
leaving sick every day and just cutting
out and you know telling my general
manager I said I'll be back tomorrow I
just got to get some sleep and I went to
probably three or four different doctors
and you know I got you have the flu you
sent me to see an ear nose and throat
specialist and they said we can't figure
anything out we think maybe you're
allergic to something so you were
misdiagnosed yeah several times in over
probably about a three-month period of
just feeling really bad it was an
allergist who suggested the CT scan that
revealed a baseball-sized tumor in his
chest
but Steve and his wife Sylvia were
determined not to let it stop them how
do you fight
the cancer and then pick up your family
and start over yeah that was hard we
almost did and I don't remember who said
it was just somebody in my oncologists
office err in New Orleans nobody told
you to stop living your life and that
was a moment where I said you're right
we're gonna move to San Antonio we're
gonna go open that restaurant and we're
gonna you know continue to live life the
way we'd planned it after he was cured
of the cancer he had a smaller problem
to solve naming his very own restaurant
we just could not figure it out but we
knew it was important we just we really
wanted it to have meaning and a friend
of mine suggested we hire a branding
company to help yes I'm serious and they
listened to what we were trying to do
with the restaurant and they listened to
my story and they came up with the name
but it seemed so obvious
yeah and I wish I could take credit for
it but I can't since opening in 2013
cured has been a James Beard Award
finalist four times including the past
three years he's currently working on a
cookbook we haven't come up with a name
yet we're working on the name of the
book nobody's eating a name boo so as
long as you get the food tastes good
[Laughter]
and it and the great thing as you can
see is Michelle brought all the food
back for who knows to produce a Greg
Merman on that one yes good stuff